- [Narrator] Once upon a time,
a war was about to happen.
The battle lines were drawn,
the soldiers were in
place, ready to fight.
But a higher power made them stop,
something unexpected and
delicious, a warm milk soup.
♪ Ooh, ooh, ooh ♪
(gentle music)
- [Narrator] Our story starts here,
in the Swiss countryside
in Kappel am Albis,
where our special peacekeeper dish
was created almost five centuries ago.
Legend has it, actually
let's get Georg on the phone.
He's a historian from
the University of Basel
and he knows this milk soup so well,
he's even written articles about it.
- [Narrator] After a while,
the soldiers got tired
and hungry so they put what
food they had together.
The Catholics brought the milk,
and the Protestants the bread.
And together they made
the legendary milk soup.
♪ Hallelujah ♪
♪ Hallelujah, hallelujah, hallelujah ♪
- [Narrator] This halted the
battle and a truce was formed.
The soup became so iconic,
it has a memorial in the battlefield,
and nearly 500 years later,
the soup is still playing peacemaker.
- [Narrator] And this is Robert,
whose restaurant has been
serving the stuff for many years.
(jaunty music)
- [Narrator] He makes
the soup the modern way,
with milk and bread of
course, but also with butter,
onions, leek, cream, vegetable stock,
and some salt and pepper.
- [Narrator] So next time you're upset
about something with your
neighbor, do as the Swiss do.
You bring the bread,
have them bring the milk,
and have a bowl of soup together.
♪ Hallelujah ♪
(electronic tone pings)